hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today we're going to be doing
a bit of a sequel to The One I released
last week this one's going to be how to
get a bond on a pay to playay new pay
to-play account uh we are using the same
one so it's not a level three but like
if you look at my stats there's not much
that's good here uh we just have some
magic levels that's pretty much it and
if you look at my bank it is empty uh
don't mind these mysterious emblems here
that is going to be for another video uh
spoiler a little bit uh cuz a lot of you
guys did enjoy the last video now we are
going to be giving away the bond today
that is going to be at the end of the
video so stay tuned for that all right
guys let's get
started all right guys we're about to
get started uh we're going to put 8
hours on the clock this time I think we
can get done un less but just in case
we'll put eight and let's get started so
we're going to start off again by uh
just picking up some ashes uh well we'll
need to wait a second here uh but the
reason we're doing this is because we
obviously have absolutely zero GP
uh which is kind of required to begin
doing anything uh from here after this
we're going to run into the Wy now we do
have a looting bag and uh we could use
it we'll probably grab the Looting bag
uh the way you get this just killing
things in the wilderness extremely easy
to do and uh yeah it's easy to get all
we really need is enough coins for a
knife and uh ideally maybe a little bit
of food as well uh pick up up these
ashes here just maybe a couple more and
then we should be good to
go not actually sure how much ashes are
worth a little bit surprisingly okay
let's see how much this we'll sell for
we just need a knife and yeah probably
some food to be
good I think knife's actually might be
more expensive than
this
knife where is the
knife uh 100 GP for the knife
all right and uh we'll buy some
wines wines again are being a very cheap
way to get a decent amount of Health
back and uh we can't afford an energy
potion no way at
all and a knife and oh anti fire Shield
we definitely need that pick up a couple
more ashes
here people lighting fires on the ashes
uh how much is the anti fire Dr anti-
dragon fire
Shield
fire
and dragon fire Shield is 126 coins uh
we'll need to grab a couple more that's
fine there seems to be a lot of Ash now
pick that up one more one more I wonder
how much money per hour you could
actually get just picking up Ash
probably not a lot tank It On The Ground
here it's probably not worth that
much okay that should be
good
and we'll buy the antifire
shield and uh we should be good to go so
for this first method here you don't
really need any requirements it can be
done on a level three all you need is a
knife an antifire shield and some food
it is recommended highly to have um at
least 24 Health cuz their Max it is 23 I
believe so I wouldn't go any less than
that and uh we'll go ahead and meet you
in
Edgeville all right so we're in
Edgeville we're just south of the bank
right now and we're going to be pulling
the lever to get into the Wilderness so
clearly this is not a safe method but uh
since we're not actually risking
anything and we are pretty low level
only level 30 I don't see this as a huge
issue so we're going to pull the lever y
teleport us to the Wilderness I am brave
enough and uh here we go it's pretty
damn quick to get here to to uh so from
here you're going to run down south to
the left of the resource area over here
to where this little hole is here and
then down here to the lava dragon aisle
uh it's a little bit of a long run but
honestly not too bad at all keep in mind
if you do take any damage and you do
happen to be below uh 23 HP I would
recommend drinking or eating a piece of
food because you don't want to get one
shot that is no fun and we'll waste
quite a bit of time I guess not in my
case that's going to suck because then
have to go ahead and redo all of this
okay so we made it to the lava dragon
aisle it only took a couple minutes to
get here so all you have to do is run in
here and just be ready to uh run past
the dragons ideally you don't want to
get H by any of them uh so if you don't
have any run energy left just save it
for when you're just going to run by
there quickly uh burnt bones don't think
those are worth very much just going to
hustle down the middle here o took a
16 heal up with the wines and where you
want to go is oh my God take a
is right here uh right here is the safe
spot all you're going to do is pick up
the white berries toss them in your
looting bag or if not just fill up an
inventory and they respawn in like two
seconds so it's pretty good so we're
going to fill up our inventory here and
uh we'll come back when that is
done all right guys there is our full
inventory done now we're going to
hustled out of here quickly hopefully
while the dragons are around I just
realized on the way in we did not even
wear our antidragon fire Shield uh but
we're bosses and we do not need it
anyway looks like these guys are going
to ignore us which is nice and so each
inventory here currently the prices of
white beares they are at about 800 or
850 each that's going to equate to about
uh 25k probably 40 to 50K for this
inventory uh which is extremely good for
not requiring very much and all you have
to do is run out of here a run takes
probably I don't know 5 to 10 minutes
really probably closer to five but yeah
we'll go back to the Grand exchange and
sell all this all right guys we're back
at the Grand exchange uh just one thing
worth noting is the uh lever does take
you back to ardun so be prepared with
either a Teleport or at least your home
teleport to get back to uh lumbridge
because it can be a long long walk
otherwise and yeah we're back so we're
going to go ahead and pull out all the
contents of our looting bag uh View and
then just uh deposit all I guess and
then withdraw them it's kind of a weird
way to do that but either way deposit
all the white berries and we got 50 in
total so that's going to be close to 50K
probably not exactly go ahead and dump
that in there and uh we got okay we got
41k I'm not too bad all we really needed
was some starting money though and that
should be good so we're going to start
off by buying a Nara
teleport and that's going to run us
about
4K a little more I
guess Narda
so the next thing we're going to be
doing is we're going to be buying
chocolate bars from God damn it's even
more
expensive uh from the Narda chocolate
Enthusiast I guess you would call it
okay let's just get this bought 7,000
come on a this thing's expensive 4.3k uh
but we only should have to do this a
couple times and yeah so we're going to
buy from the chocolate shop in Narda and
uh we'll go ahead and make sure we buy
some runes to get back first as
well I'll just buy a couple our runes
10 law runes some air
runes and uh some fire
runes just in
case now we need to get back here as
we'll collect that that leaves us with
about 34k left that's a more than enough
so we're going to take out our money so
34k and we're going to take out our
Narda teleport and that should be all we
need so once you get into Narda what
you're looking for is uh the chocolate
salesman should be pretty much right
here and over here
RoR and you can see here he sells 25
chocolate bars and it'll cost 10 each
and they sell in the grand exchange for
195 uh which is about 200 each so all
you do is buy out his chocolate shop you
can choose the H worlds or just do it
like this and then the bank is just a
little bit South so we're going to go
ahead and just do this till either our
money's done or it's been about an hour
and just see how much actually make and
we'll go for an hour hopefully and we'll
come back when we've bought all the
chocolates all right guys we just
finished up uh about just over an hour
of buying these chocolate bars and we
got about 2300 of them uh we're going to
withdraw the runes and then teleport
back to the Grand exchange and I guess
we'll see how much we made I'm guessing
about uh
400k uh which would be good that'll lead
us into our next method and that is is
going to be buying death runes from the
Wilderness shop this is a little bit
risky but has very low requirements all
I have to do is finish Rune
Mysteries and uh then you need to do the
abyss mini Quest both are extremely
short both have no requirements uh so
you can probably get them both done in
10 minutes uh which I'm going to
promptly do here but let's first off uh
sell the uh chocolate bars here we'll
just buy and sell a chocolate bar and
hopefully they um sell while we're
actually doing the quest line chocolate
bar um put in for about 250 I think
it'll buy for about
200 and 192 that's not too bad is there
much loss by selling it instantly not a
whole lot let's just pop those in there
for
186 and see how much we actually
made oh
424k uh which is pretty decent for an
hour of a method where you have no cash
to begin with and that's it guys let's
go ahead and do run Mysteries and then
the abys mini Quest and we'll get back
to you in a
minute all right so we're just about to
finish up Rune Mysteries uh this Quest
is really quick and actually a small tip
is if you use the uh necklace of Passage
it'll teleport you right to the Wizard's
uh Tower here and is a really like
honestly that took me like 3 minutes or
something and anyway there we go room
Mysteries has been completed now we have
to go and finish the abyss mini quest uh
which granted won't take too long and I
will come back when that is
done okay so we finished up the abyss
mini Quest only took about 10 minutes uh
you just have to go to a couple places
in gillor and just uh it's pretty easy
there I'll link a quest guide actually
gets you the nine room crafting as well
which is kind of nice and now we can go
ahead and do this method so what we're
going to be doing is heading back to uh
where we talked to the major zamra and
we're going to be buying his death runes
now this is absolutely risky so I want
to make that fully clear before we do
this you do need to bring a couple
hundred k at least Into the Wilderness
with you uh ideally if you had some
combat stats you'd be wearing some
defensive gear and you wouldn't really
be risking a whole lot cuz it's not very
deep in the wilderness uh but currently
I don't really have much I can wear so
it's going to be a little more riskier
for me uh while this can be done level
three it is ideal to be have some combat
stats so go ahead meet you guys out
there and we'll show you just how it
works all right guys so we're just a bit
north of Edgeville what we're going to
be doing is running out to where the Maj
of zamak was and talking to him because
now that we have completed the quest or
the mini Quest at least he will stock a
uh way more runes before he only had 50
now we can see he has like 300 so they
buy for
258 and 262 they're going to be going
for 303 on the grand exchange uh he
stocks 500 now so I think you want to
buy it till
about um let's
see um you can buy a bit more on this
maybe down to about 200 and then just
hop worlds it's really easy to do again
it's a little risky and you do have to
kind of have balls of steel because
people are going to be running at you
constantly uh because they are going to
be going into the abyss for room
crafting uh but most of them you can
ignore see that shop was bought down to
about 200 100 and once you do find a
couple worlds that haven't been hit in a
while you can make a pretty decent
profit so we're going to go ahead and
spend all our money and we'll be back
once uh well we spent all our cash all
right so that took about 10 minutes to
do that uh I thought it would last a
little longer than I forgot how much
death runes actually cost and we don't
have an agility level for that don't we
damn it anyway we'll see how much we
made in 10 minutes and see if this is
going to be worth it for us I think it
still should be
uh but we'll see all right so we'll go
ahead and uh sell the death runs back
since we do need them right away uh sell
them for I guess see
302 nope guess 301 now we something for
300 and just get it done
with so we got 530k from that so it's
about 100K in 10 minutes so that's going
to be about 600k an hour at the current
rate I'm going I believe I could
probably get the up a little bit higher
as we get a higher cash attck and
eventually you do do lose Agro uh from
the skeletons which make it a lot easier
so if you you're there for a while the
ago L is lost then uh you don't waste as
much time uh but I think we might go
ahead and do something else quickly just
to get a little bit more money before we
continue doing this uh it looks pretty
promising so because I fig figure we
need a little bit more money before we
do the death run method we're going to
do another it's not risky uh money maker
not really risky this one this one's
just a waste of time if you don't do it
right uh what we're going to be doing is
uh t
grabing uh wines of zamak and there was
just a new update today added uh that
lets you telegrab at the chaos Temple
now we're going to wear a glory and this
armor I
guess yeah sure I guess so and uh we
don't need the necklace of Passage right
now the necklace of English
or sorry the burning amulet should
teleport you right next to where we need
to go and I I guess we'll bring a little
bit of food although if someone catches
us we're kind of screwed anyway so uh
we'll go ahead and teleport out there
and we can see where we go so we're
going to go to the lava maze I think and
then from here you're just going to run
to the left and don't get confused by
teleporting to the chaos Temple because
that is a completely other our location
way down here and that's not the one you
want what you want is this one over here
is a little uh random chaos Temple just
uh west of where the teleport puts you
and don't be fooled by there actually
being nobody in there you do indeed need
to telegrab uh which is fairly
important all right so we're just going
to doing what you'd be doing on any
other uh regular telegraphing you're
just going to grab it and uh well let's
see how long it takes to respawn most
likely we'll just be hopping worlds
because I will be a little bit less
likely to be pked then although I think
hopping would be a lot
quicker and it should be able a 15sec
respawn doesn't look like they changed
it all uh so I think we'll yeah we'll
hop worlds uh even if it is kind of
risky it's about 20 seconds still I
wasn't sure if they're going to change
it with the Wilderness
Edition and any second now it should
spawn
and we'll just start hopping worlds so
we'll go do this with our 100 casts and
then we'll go probably do a couple
hundred more but we're going only going
to do 100 at a time all right we'll be
back in a minute all right so we're just
finishing up our Wes of zamra uh we keep
getting kicked from the world so we're
just going to run back now but we did uh
fill up our entire uh looting bag and
pretty much our entire inventory
realizing that we didn't actually need
to bring 50 law runes uh but yeah if you
have the uh Wilderness hard Diaries
completed you do you are actually able
to uh note the uh the things you
Telegraph which is kind of cool uh
either way I think we're going to get
about 170 or 180k or something uh from
this oh my God we should probably not
run this way uh but I think we're in
level 30 Wilderness and we can teleport
out so while I did see peers it wasn't
terribly risky honestly we'll check how
long that took us in a minute but I
definitely got the wines way quicker
than I normally would have
and if we go ahead and deposit all these
and price check obviously we need to
take off a little bit for runes but it's
not that substantial and the price check
is going to come in at about 155k so
we'll go ahead sell those and see if
this going to be worth it and if it is
we'll do this for another hour or
two all right so it just checked quickly
and that took us about 15 minutes to do
uh about I guess about 50 W of amak or
46 uh they're going to be worth I guess
they're worth a little bit less right
now unfortunately obviously the update
is crashing the price a little bit but
either way we still sold them for about
146k in profit 146k in 15 minutes is
going to equate to about 600k an hour if
you had the Wilderness hard Diaries i'
would tack on a little bit more to that
and I think we're going to go ahead and
do this seems pretty good I will do it
for at least another hour honestly that
wasn't too bad I did it for about an
hour and uh there definitely were P
carers hopping around but I didn't
really feel like it really mattered if
they killed me that much it's pretty
quick to get back here all I had was 50
law runes really at a time of course I'd
lose the zamra wines I did once uh but I
kind of like it it's not too bad and way
less crowded than uh the regular spot in
Edgeville or sorry in falor but yeah
let's just see how many we managed to
get because we we're pretty successful
we died with about 15 of them on us but
I I wouldn't say that too awful uh so
we'll go ahead and uh view our looting
bag oh we didn't fill it up whoops and
deposit those we have about
210 Wes of Zam to sell so we'll go ahead
and withdraw everything here see how
much we have in the end and then we'll
probably go ahead and start the death
Rune grind all right we're back at the
GE so let's go ahead and sell these
zamak wines off and drop them down we
sell them for 673 not quite
unfortunately a little bit lower but
that's still pretty good considering
that only took us about an hour
669k pretty damn good again with the
noted feature probably get up to about
800k although you wouldn't want to stay
there that long honestly anyways I
wouldn't say it's a huge requirement at
all so that puts us about 1.2 mil and
we're about 4 hours in so now we're
going to go ahead and buy those death
runes out and uh that should get us
between 7 800k an hour it used to be a
lot better but right now it's still
pretty decent and yeah we'll start on
that grind all right we're heading to
the Wilderness with 1.2 mil doesn't seem
like a great idea but uh we're doing it
anyway so we're going to go ahead and
buy more death runes from the shop uh
it's not terribly risky but I mean it is
1.2 mil and we could die to a skeleton
almost and yeah we'll go ahead and do
this for a little bit and come back when
we have spent all our
money all right we survived just fine uh
we ended up with 51 48 death runes uh
which we could sell
for about
1.5 6
mil roughly uh which would be about a
two or 300K profit I will double check
in a second here but pretty good took us
about 25 minutes or so and uh yeah no
uneventful just like I like it didn't
get killed or anything and we'll go
check the grand exchange for the
profit all right so we started at about
64k and we're going to sell these off
for
1554 uh so about 320k in about half an
hour maybe a bit less so about 600 to
700k an hour again that used to be quite
a bit better uh but still
700k really can't say no to that so
we'll go ahead and do that one more time
uh for well another half an hour 45
minutes or so and I'll be back in a
minute all right so we successfully
bought all these death runes from the
shop 6.2k of them uh took about 35 or 40
minutes or something and we'll go ahead
and sell these and see what we end up
with going to be pretty close to 2 mil
1871 all right so we need about another
600k or so and I think what we're going
to do now is do a couple flips now uh
we're looking at a couple items here on
G tracker for those who don't know it is
a g tracking tool that is uh pretty damn
good there's a link in the description
for that uh what we're thinking of doing
right now is the r top of Darkness rope
top bottom to be precise and uh really
good margin don't buy a whole lot but
we'll go ahead and put an offer for some
of those
138 Rob
botom
Darkness uh
138k and I'll
put three of those in and uh the other
thing we're looking at quickly was
the armal page three had a pretty decent
margin on them so they're down to about
254 uh we'll put an offer in for about
255 for those AR
page three and uh
255k these things buy pretty quick so
we'll go ahead and put offer in four I
can't afford that many
five we'll do five all right we'll come
back when these items have flipped all
right so we managed to flip these seven
items in about an hour and I think this
just might be enough to buy a bond 2338
they're a little bit down right now uh
so we're kind of looking out we'll go
ahead and sell off the rest of the stuff
we have here as well anything else of
value not
really uh we'll sell this off just in
case we need a little bit extra money I
kind of doubt it and sell all these
lobsters off won't need these
anymore and collect so we have 2350
we'll see if we can instantly buy the
bond otherwise I think we're just going
to wait it's getting kind of late and uh
well let's see I'm kind of confident I
believe can we get the
bond damn it all right guys there we go
we have successfully bought the bond it
didn't take that long to buy and luckily
the prices are a bit down so we did
actually manage to get it so we got a
bond for 2.3
mil and there we go so it took us about
6 hours to do this definitely better
than my free topl attempt probably could
have shaved a couple hours off of here
by grinding up the same method a bit
longer but I thought this would be a bit
more interesting and now for what a lot
of you guys have been waiting for the
giveaway for the last episode of my uh
from
scratch video miniseries I guess you
could call it uh we're going to draw a
name for who's going to win the bond
from last week and so we got to open
here we are going to do a random comment
I instead of doing the wheel decide
we're deciding to go with this just
because there's a lot of comments and
this will probably be a lot easier so
let's start the raffle and see who's
going to be the
winner ham 236 I just came back to
RuneScape after eight plus years I
grinded my way to a bond it's about to
run out a new Bond I'll be able to keep
flipping as a member and hopefully build
up enough cash stack to stay
self-sufficient thanks for the vids they
help a lot all right ham appreciate it
um I'll send you a message in the
comment section and once I have your
in-game name I will uh trade you the
bond so
congratulations on top of that I have
decided to give away the bond from this
episode as well uh because it seemed to
do uh well people obviously enjoy that
and it did generate a lot of comments so
for this giveaway it's going to be exact
same as the last one just leave a
comment like the video and just make
sure you are subscribed to my channel
and uh we're doing another Bond giveaway
so you have one more chance if you
didn't win definitely go and give it
another try all right guys I hope you
enjoyed the video and I will see you
guys in the next one